hey this is preshtalwalker
this is a problem that many people
cannot correctly solve
a man buys a horse for sixty dollars
he sells the horse for seventy dollars
he then buys the horse back for eighty
dollars
and he sells the horse again for ninety
dollars
in the end how much money did the man
make or lose
or did he break even
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
the short answer is the man made a
profit of twenty dollars
he made ten dollars each of the two
times he sold the horse
this is a total of twenty dollars profit
we can also see this by tracking his net
cash position
the first transaction he buys the horse
for sixty dollars
so he's out
sixty dollars this is negative sixty
dollars
relative to a starting point
he sells the horse for 70 so he then
gets plus 70
which results in a cash position of plus
10 from where he started
he then buys a horse back for eighty
dollars so he needs to spend eighty
dollars which is negative eighty dollars
so his net position is negative seventy
dollars
he finally sells the horse again for
ninety dollars which means he gets
ninety dollars
and the negative seventy plus ninety is
equal to plus twenty
in the end he makes twenty dollars
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description